I thought about what my aha moment would
be in space before I left the planet and
I thought it would be when we install
the Columbus laboratory with the robotic
arm because that was my my job and my
primary mission objective that paled in
comparison to when Peggy Whitson the
first female commander inviting us to
have a meal in the Russian segment she
said you guys bring the rehydrated
vegetables will have the meats right she
said that so we float over with this bag
of vegetables we get there and it's
African American Asian American French
German Russian the first female
commander going around the planet every
90 minutes is 17,500 miles per hour and
I felt like I was at home we're breaking
bread with people we used to fight
against the Russians in the Germans and
when I looked out the window at
Lynchburg Virginia my hometown and then
I'm thinking my parents are probably
having meatloaf down there right
five minutes later were over Paris leo
Lionhearts is looking down as parents
probably wine and cheese or something
and URIs looking off at his parents
probably eating borscht in Moscow so in
this very short period of time we are
celebrating all of humanity as we go
around the planet and that perspective
shift that I got was my aha moment and
so if millions of people can get a
chance to go to space and get this
perspective shift that I got and get
this connection back to the planet I
think it will advance our civilization
event our race the human race so
significantly so I opinion yeah
[Applause]
you
[Music]